alright so my name is Casey Stella thank
you guys for coming out guys and gals
really appreciate you guys coming hear
me talk we're good we're going to be
talking today about is natural language
processing on structured data for
structured data investigation on
actually non-textual data so I know I
kind of sort of the bait and switch you
see NLP and you think we're going to be
talking about analyzing tweets and it's
not at all how about analyzing tweets
but it's actually something I think is
cool borrowing from the cement LP
techniques some techniques for
unstructured data analysis from NLP to
use on structured data anyway I'm
getting ahead of myself so first Who am
I so I'm principal architected
Hortonworks and I focus on data science
so I'm in the consulting division I work
day to day with clients actually doing
data science for them so I primarily
work in the Hadoop ecosystem and I have
for a few years now so before this I was
doing data analysis and data mining at a
startup that was spun out of the
Cleveland Clinic it was recently
acquired by IBM called X porous we were
doing clinical data mining so you go
into the hospital we look at your
records we help the doctors know and the
hospital's know how well they actually
are performing health care for you so
it's kind of a wind 11 hospitals can I
get analytics we get money and you guys
get insights so when we went all the way
around
before that I put it around various
startups but I did signal processing on
seismic data at ion geophysical which
was in the oil industry and I was a math
grad student way back when in theater
and theoretical CS alright so domain
challenges in data science so data
science have to merge analytical skills
with domain expertise you know I get
dropped into clients so if you see over
my background there's a lot of different
domains there and it's it's not it's
sort of expected that data scientists
are able to kind of be dropped in and
understand a domain quickly and that
that's challenging all right there's a
lot of ways to understand the domain one
of them is to simply sit down and read
yeah one of them is to talk to experts
but the problem with talking to experts
I found with especially in clinical data
in seismic data that you know you talk
to experts and the experts or electrical
engineers or scientists all right
physicists in particular and they
generally know what's up oh you sent out
talk to doctors and they come with a lot
of tribal knowledge and a lot of I'm not
to say intuition but it's not exactly
they come with their own biases right
and that's that's good and it's bad it's
good to understand the biases but it's
also very good to understand what the
data is telling you and that's where
that's where unsupervised machine
learning techniques can be extremely
useful processing out what the
underlying structure of the data without
relying on people with their own foibles
and biases all right and also especially
if the data is complex lee related so
we're going to use we're going to borrow
some unstructured soup some unstructured
unsupervised structured learning from
NOP actually to apply it to the domain
of clinical data well one challenge well
first we'll talk about the technique so
i'm sure most of you have heard of word
tyvek it's relatively famous at this
point
well guys are good at what they do it's
a vectorization in the off chance that
you have it it's a vectorization model
created by google that tends to learn
the relationships between words
automatically so this is things like
finding similar words so it's changing a
problem of language into a problem of
linear algebra computer science right
uses a neural network to learn vector
representations and they're a couple
ways to do that recent work I think
that's kind of interesting and I would
urge you to look at the link that I have
down at the bottom um there was recent
work by some of the guys that I believe
Stanford at this point yeah I think so
grand many are at Stanford so dry down
the road showing that the word avec
model is actually equivalent to a
weighted word co-occurrence it's finding
the connection between word
co-occurrence and this extremely complex
neural network you know skip brand model
but it actually turns out into it turns
it turns out it translates what the
neural network is learning is
essentially a riff on word co-occurrence
right which is kind of intuitively nice
because that's what we were doing you
know forever and a day ago about you
know though backwards model it's just
it's enhanced and better but it still
links back so it's it's nice it's nice
intuitive it's not this black box in
other words i actually i'll digress
briefly one of the reasons why i say
that is it's important to understand how
to explain techniques to clients if
you're doing data science and a day to
day life because you have to talk your
audience is often executives who don't
who don't know you know haven't been in
a calculus class in a long time much
less have ever heard of deep learning in
any way other than maybe a blurb and
fortune magazine so it's it's important
to be able to explain this in our in a
reasonable way so i often find ways to
to connect with to connect complex
techniques into you know intuitive
intuitive language i guess
alright so clinical data so clinical
data is really rich and really cool and
probably very few people get to play
with it because of HIPAA and regulatory
requirements and things like that but it
is super cool it really is so when you
go into the doctor the doctor will
generally take your vitals right they'll
take your pulse take your blood pressure
etc labs are performed they'll do
they'll measure they'll draw your blood
they'll measure hba1c if they think
there's a problem with with diabetes
they'll measure your blood goop um your
blood glucose level if they think is a
problem with sugar cholesterol etc etc
all right all those things that dr. oz
talks about so much procedures are
performed if something needs to happen
diagnoses are made right after the labs
and all the things are done and drugs
are prescribed right this can be seen as
a so each of these things can be seen as
a clinical word and the only the entire
encounter gave me seen as a clinical
sentence with some structure and
inherent into it right so the idea the
hypothesis is that you can use the
structure like you use any other natural
language sentence and you can use the
techniques of word tyvek to find the
connections in between each of these
clinical words so find the most related
diagnosis by looking at by looking at
diagnosis that were used in a similar
way in the same context in a similar
context right okay um so one of the
challenges is actually finding data all
right um very few people have you know a
bunch of very personal clinical data
just bouncing around the internet at
least not the one can use with any sort
of ethics um so but it turns out there
was an electronic medical record system
that was looking to predict people who
had diabetes so they depersonalized
10,000 patient records 10,000 patient
encounters I should say more more
records
and um put them as part of the catechol
competition and it did you know I
ingested and pre-processed this in
Hadoop it's a small amount of data but
if anyone is in is dealing with medical
data you understand that there's a Larry
actually most most insurance companies
those hospitals have a lot actually a
lot of data so it does fit very well
with in Hadoop so I ingested the data
and transformed it using pig and hive
hive to store the actual records and pig
to to do the ETL to transform them into
sentences and to normalize them kind of
scrub some of the bad data because the
other thing you'll find out in
healthcare data is it's extremely noisy
so that's about eighty percent of the
actual problem okay so if you're
interested in the cattle competition
it's from 2012 and the link is at the
bottom you can these this deck will be
available after okay so okay that looks
terrible hello
oops
okay so kind of as a preview for my
takut summit if you guys are attending I
recently become interested in using
notebooks for data science I know this
is not new but in particular notebooks
integrating with Hadoop for doing some
data science so what I decided to do is
I was going to use the the python
bindings for spark because spark as of
1.2 has a very nice word tyvek
implementation right there available and
I have these nice sentences just itchin
to be analyzed using word tyvek so it's
actually quite easy to do most the work
was in the etl I can pull the
information from a text file and the
rest of this are nice little Python
functions to to pretty print the results
and define the nearest neighbors right
easy-peasy so one thing so what the
things I wanted to find I'm going to
figure out if we could do one or two
things so the methodology to determine
if my hypothesis was correct then that
we could extract these structure that
this the structured connection from
these clinical sentences these clinical
encounters is can i recover things that
we know about from the domain of
medicine and can i see if i can find
something novel so if i if i find a
bunch of stuff that's obviously wrong
right if i can't find the obvious
connections then you're not going to
believe me whenever I find something not
obvious right so after o sclerosis of
the aorta that's a big one right tons of
people are dying of heart disease all
day every day hardening of arteries it's
a it's a terrible terrible thing so if
you've ever worked in the medical
industry this is what's called an icd-9
code it's a diagnosis code so what I'm
finding is I'm finding the the closest
clinical synonyms to atherosclerosis and
you see the first one right at the top
as peptic ulcers so we've known this
connection since the 60s probably before
actually the earliest i could find was
an editorial in the British Medical
Journal way back in the 1970s saying
that this was known so it was known in
the 1970s and part of the
or so that you can see that this is
actually you know a strong connection we
know this and it bubbles right at the
top so we're feeling that feeling pretty
confident about the technique this is
good so the first few are about peptic
ulcers the other diagnoses around peptic
ulcers there was one that was kind of
interesting was this one since Soren
neural hearing loss unspecified so what
that is is hearing loss so why would
hearing loss be connected to
atherosclerosis so this is one of the
recent connections we found in 2012 so a
quote from an article in the Journal of
in the journal of atherosclerosis saying
since our neural hearing loss seem to be
associated with vascular endothelial
dysfunction and an increased
cardiovascular risk so you see that
hearing loss and cardiovascular risk are
strongly connected and you do see that
in the data borne out we found that in
2012 we found that from 10,000 patient
records that were open sourced in five
minutes on my laptop actually lots of
less than five minutes that's kind of
neat I think knee joint replacements so
some of these things are you know you're
you're diving into the correlation you
know category old people have often get
often have atherosclerosis and they
often get knee joint replacements but
you see you see that it does find that
connection which is right here so yeah
it is finding its its it's finding the
things that we obviously know and it's
finding the things that were not
necessarily as obvious which is nice one
thing I thought so the next one I want
to look at was Crohn's disease it's a
common one it's not necessarily just
from the elderly I wanted a kind of a
voi one really focuses on diseases of
the elderly kind of wanted to focus on
you know something that happened mi
happen to two people you know who were
younger Crohn's disease an inflammatory
bowel disease and is fairly common it's
caused by a combination of environmental
immune and bacterial factors I thought
this was kind of neat
so one thing that it found was the first
one the top one is chronic Goudy
arthropathy so arthropathy is arthritis
right it finds a connection between
Crohn's and arthritis krone arthritis is
the most common comorbidity with crohn's
so it finds the thing at the very
bubbles right to the top the thing that
is the most connected with crohn's um
the thing that I found with it was
interesting was the second-most connect
strongly connected is the is a abscess
of the teeth so a dental abscess is
connected with crohn's and i thought to
myself that's very strange why would
Crohn's have a connection with dentistry
and your mouth and if you think about it
your alimentary canal the top your
gastrointestinal system starts at your
mouth so if you have inflammatory bowel
disease it's and it has issues with your
with your with the entire
gastrointestinal system and it bubbles
into the mouth actually it does connect
to the mouth and that is you can see
that if you look in the Crone's forums
with people who were suffering from
Crohn's you see a lot of discussion
about dental abscesses you don't see a
lot in the literature so this is
something that i don't i don't think is
as known in the in the literature but is
seen in the in the in real life i guess
if you're to take in and it forms to be
real life which you probably shouldn't
and finally i think the most interesting
one was this one that is yeast
infections there is a strong connection
between yeast infections in particular
there is some belief amongst researchers
that yeast that a that a the immune
response to yeast infections is one of
the causes of crohn's disease we found
this out relatively recently i believe
this was from 2014 so it's still being
it says it's still being researched but
this is the first time that they're
really taking this connection seriously
and you see
it bubble right to the top in connection
in finding these connections of the data
so the other thing that's kind of nice
about this model is that it's not just
about it's not just about matching
diagnosis the diagnosis you can also
cross match different types of different
types of clinical words so in this
situation I want to find the the most
associated drugs with hiv/aids right and
so you see right at the top the triple
cocktail so that's a common that's a
common cocktail of drugs given to HIV
patients to prevent them from getting
AIDS and the second one you see is proc
side topical peroxide same thing you use
to bleach your hair if you're into that
sort of thing the reason why is it is
used to treat skin med it's so the the
the connection is there are the topical
emollients are used to help soothe the
skin and a particular peroxide has
helped to to dry the skin out slightly
fit as a result of some of the some of
the side effects of the HIV medication
you see that throughout the HIV forums
as well so the point here was to show
kind of a few vignettes of of some data
investigation finding this instruction
finding the connections in this
unstructured data using very simple
techniques that is not in the domain of
really data mining that most people
think of and that's really Yeah right
there any questions just call ID yes
connection you found out
disease was any particular altering of
this connection so we were able to
finance and the significance of
difference connection yes so that's a
good question so I'll repeat it so the
question was is there any significance
to the television being honest here is
there any significance to the rankings
is one more connect is one more
connected than the other and this is
cosine similarity so it's really me the
way to interpret it is there is a vector
and that is and then is disconnected the
closer it is to one the closer it is to
fully connected the closer it is to zero
the closer is to not connect it's cosine
similarity now are there cut offs and or
they'll cut those do those cut offs mean
something I have not found anything that
i would really so i would say anything
above from just just looking at the data
anything above a point seven was a
fairly strong connection anything below
a point seven looked kind of bad if
you're dealing with one clinical armed
with with one word to with if you're
comparing diagnosis the diagnosis when
you're comparing diagnosis to other
kinds of of clinical words like drugs
you'll have to go a little bit farther
out something like point 52.3 was a
strong connection I don't say but that's
again you know kind of looking at the
data and rule of thumb kind of thing
unfortunately yeah I wish I had a better
principal to answer for you yeah well
they actually it's a funny it's funny
I've actually solved this problem as
part of a team at client sites and it
was a riff on tf-idf with a custom IDF
function that was not your normal idea
function and it found the connections
just the same right it's the same kind
of thing and it's again it's a riff on
on NLP techniques which kind of belies
my background probably so sorry about
that if I were if I were being honest
probably one another another principled
approach to this and what I probably
should have done and I want to do is
look at just plain correlation right
what are the most correlated right in
just in terms of
that would also give some insight but
this is this is at least tf-idf model
did do better than simple correlation
and I suspect this actually will do
better than simple correlation as well
yes dan the connection we didn't p is
the context I the notion that a certain
word is embedded in a local context
that's more important than the overall
document right so they let waiting that
you mention it was like maybe you said
that but I missed it how what was the
notion of that context so that forwards
is worth it are near in in the text
right so the context is actually
temporal and you often have these things
in in order right when you go to the
doctor you get you get certain things in
order you get you generally get seen
first youíve vital right your vitals are
taken and then there is either their
labs ordered a diagnosis made and these
things happen you know in the course of
time for an entire encounter right so
that's that that if sort of forms that
you can think of it as forming a grammar
in of itself what these things are
connected together you really have to
have the lab you have to have the diet
you have to have the lab before you
really have the diagnosis and things
like that that's the hope that you'll
find the inter connection isn't that the
organ attacks that is mapped to an order
a temporal order of in which these
things have happened that's right and
about the length of this context is it
like based on time steps or you go like
five events in the past and five in the
future so the way that the way that the
word tyvek implementation works at is
part of ml lib which is what I used you
can specify window and the default
window is five and for the most part
that worked out fairly well I did tinker
around with the windows five seemed to
work the best what I saw the way that I
did that again was kind of rule of thumb
right i tinkered around with it I said
this looked good this gave me good
results this gave me bad results because
I could actually Google these things and
find the connections I had a I had him I
had an objective function to kind of
optimized right as long as as long as
atherosclerosis was bubbling peptic
ulcers up to the top I was pretty happy
with the results right and then I could
if you could do something more
sometimes time so you say like a month
before and after oh it's it's for an
encounter so an encounter is out like
they're split in two episodes right when
you go to the doctor you know and you
have this diagnosis it is an encounter
it is distinct from the separate account
of that is already split up there
there's a cleanse their clinical
meanings for that that is the the notion
of sentence associates with the notion
of an encounter which is a set of
clinical words or clinical occurrences
if you will yeah so if I pushed a
metaphor of language to delimit then
basically you bid stories yes and
certain illnesses to probability because
you'll have template of a story the same
like the stupid novels whatever are we
didn't you know within yes so and then
the implication would be or is if I me
just make sure that thing at it is okay
this the beginning of this story looks
similar to this chunk of stories
therefore let me rush that because I
know then that's the implication more
like the word that you using this story
is used similarly in other kinds of
stories so this word is associated with
this other word and these other stories
because they're used in the same way so
they're probably the mean the same thing
now what you're talking about is we'd be
running what's called doc tyvek which is
a vectorization of a document which is
very interesting i think and i haven't
done that yet and I do intend on doing
it so that would be you take an
encounter and you find similar
encounters to that so you have the
notion of maybe a good encounter or
maybe a bad encounter and you can file
or maybe a diabetic encounter or an
encounter it so you can know before you
go in maybe early that you're likely to
have diabetes because you've had these
series of encounters leading up right
that will be an interesting extension to
this this is just kind of the bare bones
these are words are the individual you
know the individual clinical words the
synonyms any analogies the other thing
that we're tyvek does is actually
analogy are you because you're in a
vector space you can do things like
king- male
was it can- mail plus female is is a
similar vector to Queen right so you can
do these same kinds of things with with
these clinical words you can take this
diagnosis subtract this diagnosis and
maybe see if there's a connection
between these other digests like type 2
diabetes minus some very very important
comorbidity of type 2 diabetes is it
similar to type 1 diabetes I'm not the
reason why I didn't do that is I
couldn't find a real world use case for
that one other than just it's neat to do
um but anyway any other questions yeah
that was a bit more of the metric abused
you yeah so this is this is so here's
one challenge with the word tyvek
implementation for 4 ml lib is your
you're bound to a cosine similarity
unfortunately so the training in all of
that business it's unsupervised sort of
happens under the hood and your you kind
of have to fit you kind of have to live
with your vector space that they create
the tuning parameters that you really
have our window length so like I said
basically it was kind of hand coded yeah
I knew it was going to be somewhere
between it was sort of a hand grid
search writing you is so I'm going to be
somewhere between three and five because
that made the most sense because these
clinical encounters were only I mean
some of them were only five long right
so that it didn't make sense to go more
than five ish a lot of them were only
five long so a lot of it a lot of them
the ways that you tune it is looking at
looking at your data and figure out what
kind of makes sense and then running it
a few times to see what what you have to
pick an objective function and maximize
in this situation it was very much a
qualitative objective function do I
still recover the things that I know are
connections in the data right from a set
of diagnosis in a set of drugs and as
long as I did I picked the this the set
of parameters of to fit the best but I
know it's kind of a loosey goosey
methodology but you have
mini you don't have very many levers to
pull as it were any other questions yeah
the keywords have you take a look at the
cake key phrases yeah so um I didn't I
so you mean are the these these these by
grams essential clinical by grams are
these connected no I didn't do that yet
that's in Chance an interesting question
it is one challenge about that is it's
hard to interpret or it's easy for it's
easy to if I go to a doctor and say hey
you want to know that everything that
all the diagnosis that connect to
atherosclerosis and the doctor says
absolutely that's what they taught me in
medical school well this is what the
computer thinks it is but you want to
know all the diagnosis pairs that
connect to atherosclerosis and Goudy and
gout and they're ever like maybe that
might be useful for me yeah um actually
you because you first yeah right like
this honestly this isn't going to
replace dr. no and fundamental diseases
as you plan out similar to what it
learns a little railing yep what
diagnosis similar like what symptoms
lead to what diagnosis so is the idea
that you take this and then as you say
fine powerful heritage of these models
such that you can
things that are rare like the sort of
unexpected combinations yeah here's what
I would like to see because it's four
out of ten thousand patient out of ten
thousand patient encounters you start
finding things that we only found in
2012-2013 I would like to see a much
larger corpus run on this and fed into
the medical research establishment to
say hey are these connections between
these things to kind of seed the
research these are the things that the
computer things are connected find a
causal relationship between them as best
you can that's what I would love to see
you know in terms of a dream connection
problem is they're they're very few
people with that much data and they're
very few people with that much data with
the willingness to do pure research
often write any rate that's what I would
like I do not see this this is not
Watson in a box right it's not Watson on
my Mac and spark but it does find
connections the day the other thing I
would like to say is this is this is
temporal data right it's just it's just
temporal connections with some sort of
grammar associated with it we see this
all over the place I just mean in
automatically mining the the connections
between data and relational databases
would also work with this if you can
form a sequence of things with a grammar
around it or with it even with a
grandmother you don't entirely
understand you can use this kind of
thing by forming it into sentences in
using the embargo in from the techniques
of NLP will be very useful that's one of
the benefits of Hadoop is that you're
not i mean you can you can start doing
these these these sort of non not these
this unstructured data and this on the
semi-structured data analysis right eye
is that that's probably enough time of
questions you guys can ask after thank
you